Te souviens-tu ? On avait tondu des bonnes bebars dans un salon de coiffure à l'époque
Putain je rêverais de faire ça
Et de voir des poils aussi longs tomber de mon visage
Aujourd'hui on veut devenir barbier professionnel et ouvrir notre propre salon
Bienvenue sur Trimmer Tycoon,
ce n'est pas un simulateur de mec qui trime...
*LE BON GROS MALAISE*
(rire) avec la musique ça le faisait carrément ce bide
c'est un p'tit jeu en pixel art on en fait
pas souvent et pourtant c'est très très cool, c'est parti,
je découvre ça avec vous, j'espère qu'on va être plus fort
que quand on avait dû gérer des cams girls là dans
euh... Hunie... Pop  Cam euh... Studio.
Moins 1300, on est endetté jusqu'à la mort, j'avais pas vu. On est mort !
Clique sur un client
pour t'occuper de sa barbe
C'est parti ! J'ai choisi lui
Il veut une barbe comme ça du coup. Ah mais c'est chaud en fait, va falloir compter les cases à fond
*Squeezie se concentre*
*Musique de Hacker bien bien stylée*
Merde ! Merde j'ai coupé un bout de la stachmou !
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave, c'est pas grave, c'est pas grave ! Bah je l'ai fait un peu en décalé.
Eh franchement mec j'm'en bas les couilles, franchement démmerde toi
*Musique triste*
Oh j'ai n*qué la game, je lui ai tout fait de travers.
Ah merde ! Mais il voulait un truc sur le côté.
Eh mec, c'est impossible de faire ça aussi. Bon mec, tu sais quoi ?
On va juste te faire un bouc, je t'épargne, et on va te la teindre en bleu.
Ah mais il y a un ciseau ! Putain ! Moi j'ai tout fait à la tondeuse. C'est pour ça que je me suis foiré.
Ok, on lui fait bien bleu. C'est parti, il a kiffé ?
Ouais, il nous a payé. Il a kiffé !
*musique joyeuse #carrefour j'optimise! *
Putain, le pauvre.
Alors, les distractions attirent les consommateurs, clique sur le PC pour en acheter. Bah ok.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut s'acheter ?
Quoi, un porte-manteau, ça attire des gens ?
Une plante. Une plante ! Souvent les gens qu'ont des barbes, c'est des putains d'hipsters.
Et les hipsters, ça adore quoi ? Ça adore les plantes.
Boum ! On va la mettre juste là.
Il pourra poser ses pieds dessus comme ça quand je lui toucherai sa barbe.
Comme ça, il gardera bien les pieds sur terre. Vous avez compris le jeu de mots. C'était excellent ! *musique*
Putain ! Dans une minute, je dois payer 200$ de taxes ! Mais c'est abusé, mec !
Qu'est-ce que tu veux ?
Oh oui, ça c'est super simple.
Déjà, pourquoi vous avez tous des barbes de huit mois ? Mec, sans déconner ?!
Oh ! Ce que je suis en train de lui faire, mon gars.
Mon gars, j'suis on fire.
Regardez, regardez ! comme je suis perfectionniste.
Ça, ça fait la réputation du salon, ça hein.
Je lui ai fait pile ce qu'il voulait mon gars !
*Alarme* "Non, c'est faux" (voix du Joker)
Juste un petit carré là, un p'tit carré là.
Ohlalala ! Combien il me donne ? Quoi ?!
Il m'a rien donné. Mais là je vais fermer déjà mec.
Ah, merde ! J'ai oublié de lui teindre la barbe, c'est pour ça ! Raah putain ! *Gémissements*
Le barbier qui fait un AVC, quoi *Gémissements*
*Musique Triste* :'(
Game over, vous avez survécu trois minutes. (Loser.)
Super !
Bon cette fois, mec, on perd pas de temps.
On rase plus de poils que dans sa...
Ah putain
P'tain ! J'étais en train de dire ma vanne, et je l'ai oublié. #alzeimer
Ça m'était encore jamais arrivé.
Alors, je vais acheter une fourniture.
On va racheter une plante qu'on va mettre là.
Viens-là ! Toi, ok.
Il veut quoi ? Oh putain, il veut un truc bien relou.
Mec, je vais lui faire ça en 2-2.
Voilà, ça c'est fait.
Ta barbe, elle vole mec, c'est n'importe quoi !
*Musique de X-Files*
Il faut arrêter.
Ok, tu la veux quoi ? Une sorte de vert un peu clair comme ça là ?
Voilà mec ! 232$ ! Il a kiffé mon pote.
Toi viens-là. Ah, il veut le truc chiant.
Mec, je m'en bats les cou*lles, on va y aller au feeling.
Bon, n*que sa mère !
N*que sa grosse mère !
Voilà ! Franchement, ce que tu as, c'est vraiment génial !
Il m'a donné 136$, ça lui a plu.
Ça lui a grave plu, mec.
Toi, viens-la. Quoi ?! Mais qui fait ça ?!
MAIS QUI FAIT ÇA ?!
Mais qui fais ça mec ? Sans déconner c'est un sketch.
Boh attends on va lui laisser comme ça . Je me suis foiré.
Franchement mec j'ai failli réussir. Nan j'te jure.
Du coup si t'est un p'tit peu indulgent indulgent t'es cool. *Points d'interrogation apparaissant un peu partout.*
Par contre le niveau de couleur on est vraiment ... *Bruit de Bouche* Al Dente.
Et bim ! 184$ ! On peut engager un barbier
On a pas assez de salles. Quoi ?!
Ça coûte combien d'agrandir sa salle ?
2000$ ?! P*tain..
Voila t'as kiffé, t'as... Ah merde ! J'ai oublié les "pattes" !
C'est pas grave, Starfoullah . -104$, ça fait plaisir.
'tain, j'ai du le payer carrément cet enc*lé, je le déteste.
Prochaine fois, j'le refuse direct.
Toi tu veux ça, mec. Franchement c'est moche.
On va s'contenter d'une p'tite moustache, c'est très très bien.
Ouais, mec. C'est pas beaucoup mieux comme ça ?
On dirait Jean-Michel inspecteur dans Narcos.
*Image de Pedro Pascal avec musique à la guitare désaccordée.*
Voila c'est stylé . VOILAA 120$
Allez on enchaîne !
Mais pour... C'est quoi ça ? C'est une nouvelle mode ça
Oh p*tain lui j'lui ai bien fait vous avez vu ?
Hop j'te laisse un cas de poils sur le pulse
C'est la nouvelle mode qui remplace la mode des pinss finalement
C'est le même effet je t'assure c’est-à-dire que tu m'as pécho 0 meuf
Allez c'est parti 136$ hoo on lance des modes
Mais mec je paye de plus en plus gagne de moins en moins
Je me plains beaucoup j'suis désolé
Je me plains plus que ta maman quand elle rentre du travail
C'est quand même te dire
Ça vous plaît quand je parle de votre maman comme ça?
De manière positive ou pas? Moi ça me plaît énormément
J'peux pas engager j'peux rien faire . J'suis comme un c...
On peut pas augmenter les prix ?
Y'a pas un truc pour augmenter les prix ?
Mec j'me ruine j’achète une table *BOOM*
'tain mec 'faut qu'on enchaîne sinon on va perdre
Voila c'est très bien
Une p'tite roue par la hop p*tain t'as fait un truc vraiment stylé
Mon gars avec cette bebar t'as pas besoin de cache-oreilles, c'est l'avantage
C'est parti c'est gratuit bim... 200$
Voila boom allez on enchaîne !!!
Qu'est-ce tu veux mon gars ?
C'est incroyable c'est incroyable ce que j't'ai fait
Fait moi confiance j'suis pas le barbier numéro 1 du quartier pour rien
Hop la +120$
Oh p*tain ça va super vite tout c'qui s'passe
Oh ça c'est bien euuh...
Bien rouflaquette tout ça
Vraiment qu'un jour j'me mette à utiliser le ciseau finalement
Parce que la j'm'en bat les co*****s
Et ça marche il m'donne des tunes moi j'ai pas fait d'effort et il m'donne les tunes
Allez on va aller sur le ciseau c'est parti
Oh c'est super chiant oh C'EST SUPER CHIANT
Ça dégage
C'est moi ou on lui a fait un truc incroyable a ce mec
Oh y a Chris Brown (???) dans le salon écoutez
*Everything like eh eh oh* eh oh eh oh
(il rigole en plus)
C'est une coupe que j'ai appelé la barre fixe
Pourquoi la barre fixe ? Parce qu'un gymnastique peut s'y accrocher et faire des soleils
voila
Il a atterri, il a 10/10 par le jury c'est super
Cette blague était trop longue mais tu va me payer 256$ pour la barre fixe BOOM (de Tibo inshape)
Ça me prend au tripes ce jeu là.
Bon nouvelle propal, le collier en perles de ta maman sous forme de barbe
Ça lui fera plaisir elle se verra a travers toi.
M*rde j'ai foiré
280$ pour ça
*rire*
Ah les mecs ils ont pas la valeur des choses
Même pour une coupe de malade, 280$ déjà tu paye pas
Bon aller, les ciseaux, ok j'ai compris.
Mais il coupe pas !! Vas-y !
Mais WTF ? Eh ton ciseaux il a un problème mec. Aller, ça dégage
Et il me donne 104$ voilà, pigeon, je m'en bas les c**lles
Toi, tu veut la barbe à Cyprien, il n'y a pas de soucis
Bah oui !
208$ ? P*tain il avait autant d'argent que Cyprien en plus
Et, et, et c'était Cyprien.
Abonne-toi
*rire*
J'ai tenté une escroquerie, il s'est pas fait avoir le c*n
Ah mais lui il est abonné à "30 millions de consomateurs", c'est sûr hein ?
Attends, j'ai pas mixé le nom de 2 associations là ?
500$ dans une minute, ça mec c'est mort. C'est fini, c'est fini.
Ah ! Ça j'aime bien les clients comme ça. Ça c'est les mecs qui font vivre les salons de barbiers
Regarde, hop, hop, hop, voilà. Starfoula. Voilà osef, on dirait une game de tetris sa barbe
Hop là ! 240 !!!
Ta gueule !
Pardon, mais c'était.....
C'est......
Ouais, j'ai pas d'excuse.
J'ai envie d'terminer la vidéo maintenant parce que je trouve qu'on a fait toutes les blagues et les vannes possibles !
Voilà !
Et ce jeu est trop dur
Allez c'est parti
168$ Yes
Yes !! Allez allez on peut l'faire
280 !!!!
OOOOH
Je prends un employé attention !!
Ah merde 'faut acheter une chambre avant c'est vrai :|
Et celle-la ça coûte 2000$
C'est impossible
Attends j'aimerai recommencer
Ça s'trouve quand tu fais une coupe à la perfection
Il te donne genre 5000$ d'un coup
On va essayer
Regardez ! Le ciseau, il marche pas, il coupe rien.
Ah bah là, ça coupe d'un coup hein ?
Pourquoi des fois il coupe et des fois il coupe pas ? :|
C'est ça que j'comprends pas
Bon mec, j'te fais un nouveau style, j'm'en bat les co**lles
Si tu refuses les conseils d'un pro t'es con. Voilà! 48$
Voilà! (la musique de Pirates de Caraîbes et la photo de Davy Jones)
Non mais plus compliqué quoi ?
Le mec il veut que j'lui fasse une barbe omega
Attends et si juste j'l'a teint il m'donne la tune ?
On va faire que des teintures
Ah non clairement pas
Ok mec lui on va lui faire a la perfection c'est parti
Attends mec là, on lui a fait un truc de ouf
Attends là, c'est abusé la ressemblance
176$ vous êtes de mauvaise foi monsieur
Bon j'avoue ça a aucun style *rire*
On dirait un smiley qui dance cette putain d'barbe
YEAH super ce barbier
Voila bah c'est sur cette excellente blague de m*rde
Que cette vidéo s’achève . J'espère que ça vous a plu
Si le cas n’hésitez pas a l'aimer comme d'habitude
Franchement c'est méga dur
J'vous jure, c'est plus dur que Dark Souls ce jeu quoi putain
Moi j'croyais couper des barbes et faire carrière dans un branche viril de la... de la euuuuh...
...démocratie finalement
Et j'me retrouve la sur la touche
Du coup j'ai fait c'que tous les kassos font quoi : être Youtuber
Allez merci d'avoir regarder la vidéo
On se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine
Portez vous bien
vous et votre barbe soyeuse et douce
chao la démocratie
Peace